sure uh right there uh in the red
yeah right in front of you
the lady is red thank you um i'm
curious about the process of creating
characters
um you said it when you created the
characters in the beginning you knew
what was going to happen
to them what about the characters that
appear
later in in the books
did you uh know that they were going to
exist what about excuse me what about
which characters
i mean uh the ones that come later
in book three for example
um when they are in the north
uh some of some characters that appear
did you have the idea that they were
going to be
in your book or they
you decided not necessarily i mean i i
knew the major shape of the major
characters i didn't necessarily know all
of the
minor characters and of course there are
lots and lots and lots of minor
characters
um but if you look
if you can find a first edition
or an old edition from the 1990s of game
of thrones
and you look at the original appendix
in the back of the book you'll see many
character names
some of them still haven't appeared but
i
had plans for all of those characters i
mean i created them and put them in
there because uh eventually i i would
have some rule for them
so um
if they're not in the game of thrones
appendix i probably hadn't thought of
them at that point and they were people
who uh who showed up later
and because the appendix gets longer and
longer just as the books do i mean by
by the time of uh dance with dragons the
appendix is practically a novel by
itself here
and concludes many things i i didn't
know beginning that
danny wouldn't necessarily be meeting
all these particular people in the city
of marine for example
um i i just knew in broad senses that
she would be
eventually going to uh slavers bay and
uh
acquiring some unsullied soldiers you'll
see that the unsullied are in there
they're in
you see the unsullied in manchester
illyrio's mance
so i already had the unsullied in mind
but i didn't have all the things
developed so it's a kind of an organic
process
that goes on at least sylvia
quest asked if you have to live
in one of the cities in the west wares
which one do you choose and why
if i had to live in one of the cities of
westeros
uh i suppose i would choose old town
which you haven't seen much of but
it's got the citadel there which has a
really good library
and uh you know i would probably be a
maester or something like that
and then going in there and reading the
library and teaching
teaching ravens how to study uh how to
carry messages and
uh that sort of thing i i think that
sort of life suits me a lot better than
wielding
a sword i would not last very long as a
swordsman i fear
never know one last question from the
crowd
up there can i uh first of all
thank you for being here and my question
is
how can you think of so many characters
in so well shaped characters
do you base yourself on the people you
know to write them i base the characters
on yeah on people i know based on
characters on
characters from history i don't just
take a character from history though and
file off the uh
the name and attach a new name to it
that kind of one-to-one thing has never
interested me i'll take a
aspect of a certain character and meld
it with an aspect of another character
and a touch of imagination and hopefully
come up with someone who is uh not an
exact duplicate of a historical
character but
is well enough grounded in reality to be
uh
plausible and for the viewpoint
characters of course
i i look inward i look at myself
it's true that many of the characters in
the books the viewpoint characters are
are not like me at least to a surface
surface examination uh you know i've
never been an
exiled prince i am not a dwarf
i've never been an 11 year old girl
but all of these people despite
whatever else may be happening to them
whatever particular burdens
they have to bear or whatever forces
have shaped them through their lives
are human beings first and foremost and
i i think our common humanity is the
thing that unites us far more than our
differences divide us and i always try
to keep that in mind and
you know when i'm writing a character
you know look look inward and try to
think how i would feel in that situation
and remember that uh
you know as they say in casablanca it's
all the same old story a fight for love
and glory
i i think our motivations that drive all
human beings are
kind of the same and sometimes we need
to be
reminded that that we're all alike under
the skin